good morning to you john langler with
you here poolside
at the new downtown las vegas circa
resort
hector mejia is live inside to finish
off that chat over in the vegas vicki
lounge hector good morning
good morning to you john sorry about
those uh technical issues technology
these days
so we were just talking about the
architecture and design here we have
alice o'keefe
to talk to us about it so you oversaw
everything that had to do with the
design
architecture how are you guys able to
incorporate old vegas
with new vegas well
a lot of it is in the details right so
down to the carpet
the use of obviously vegas vicky the
custom wall covering all of that we've
taken
small design details from all the eras
so the 20s the 40s the 60s 80s
and put it all together and in doing
that it really creates a new look
and if you really pay attention you can
really tell okay good
that's good so you were telling me an
interesting
fact earlier that about 90 percent of
the art you see here
is from local artists yeah yeah it was
really important to me
being downtown kind of right in the
heart of the arts district that we use
a lot of the local talent that we
already have so um
really i mean i could point out all the
all of it but um
really great to be able to have that
because i there's not really any project
like that that i know of so it's really
great accomplishment
it's amazing to hear and so obviously a
very monumental day
not only for circa but everyone here in
town when you look back to this day
years or decades to come what do you
think you'll make out of today
i i just hope that it's memorable for
everyone and that people are able to see
that i mean just in the the time with
everything going on in the world
that we're really creating something new
and giving people something to come to
las vegas
for that's really exciting alice thank
you for your insight
well there you have it we're reporting
live inside you circa resort opening
tonight at midnight
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you